-Our next guest is the talente
filmmaker behind films lik
"Baby Driver," "Shaun of
the Dead" and "Hot Fuzz."
His debut documentary,
"The Sparks Brothers,"
will be in theaters tomorrow
Let's take a look.
-As a synthesizer duo,
I guess you could say that
they sort of set a template.
-♪♪ You gotta beat the clock
you gotta beat the clock ♪
-I became first aware of Spark
in their 1979 period,
seeing them on, like,
"Top of the Pops"
around that time.
You know, it's a very sort o
stark dynamic image --
Russell singing,
Ron on the synths.
He had his '79
kind of hipster hair.
-Sparks and a new single
called "Beat the Clock."
-I think it is real great.
-Please welcome back
to the show Edgar Wright.
Edgar, how are you?
-I'm good.
Thanks for having me back, Seth.
-It's such a pleasure
to see you.
You're in London.
-I am in London.
-And a lot of press for a whil
has been Zoom only,
but now there are some in-person
events for your documentary.
Here's one in LA
that you Zoomed into
in a very, like, "1984" fashion.
You really kind of
took over the room.
-I know.
Your American embassy
wouldn't grant me a visa waive
to come over and do press
because it's nonessential work
doing press.
What we're doing right now
is not important.
But I did -- Because
Ron and Russell from Sparks,
they did their first,
like, in-person Q&A,
and so not to let them down,
I did that zoom
at 5:00 a.m. London time.
But I hadn't really factored
into the fact
that I was going to be
on a cinema screen
because nobody needs
to see my face that big.
I look a bit like Kim Jong-un...
like, threatening to derai
the premiere of "The Interview
or something.
-What's nice --
-It almost looks like
I've got a Nehru jacket on
right now.
-Now, it's --
is it nonessential?
Do you think they would have
felt the same way if you had
say, directed a Marvel film?
Do you think they were
specifically knocking you
for having directed
a documentary?
-I don't know. Maybe I got
demerits just being British.
I am not sure.
Anyway, I mean, I haven't been
in the same room as the guys
since I shot the movie,
so, at some point,
we'll actually
be able to watch the film
together.
But, you know,
I'm happy to be here, of course.
-As we saw in the clip,
not only are you the directo
of this film,
you interview yourself, I guess.
You are listed as a fanboy
This is a band that you have
loved for a very long time
that you --
Have you been surprised
over the years that more peopl
didn't know them?
Or is that what
you've come to expect?
-I come to expect it because
as I said in the clip,
I was like 5 years old
when I saw them on TV.
But in a pre-Internet age,
as we remember, um,
it was very difficult
to get information on bands,
like, beyond what might be
in a magazine
or on the radio or on the TV
Before the Internet
and before Spotify
having somebody's
entire discography,
it was quite difficult
to pin bands down.
So they were a band that kep
coming back into my life.
And as that happened
more and more frequently,
I became
more and more obsessed.
They went from
being a riddle to me
to being, like,
a full-on obsession.
So I think in the last 20 years,
I've become, you know,
not just a fan,
but, you know, that kind o
evangelist with a band
where you're grabbing anybod
within your eye view to say,
"Hey, have you ever heard
Sparks? Listen to this!"
-You talk about the technology
that wasn't available to u
as music fans
when we were growing up,
but you did use
the modern technology of Twitter
to make contact with these guys.
-Well, actually, bizarrely
on one of my frequent marathon
of making somebody
in the same room
as me listen to Sparks...
[ Laughs ]
I suddenly thought, after having
been a big fan of them,
I never, like,
followed them on Twitter.
So I said, "I wonder if Sparks
have a Twitter profile."
And I looked at it, and it said,
"Sparks follows you,"
which was so shocking to m
because, you know,
like, some artists --
They're very enigmatic,
Ron and Russell from Sparks,
a bit like Kate Bush
or David Bowie.
And all of those people,
you don't imagine
they live on planet Earth.
So then I immediately
direct-messaged them.
Well, first,
I followed them back,
and then I direct-messaged the
and said,
"Is this really the band?
I'm such a huge fan."
And Russell, the lead singer
messaged me back and said,
"Yeah, we're big fans
of your films."
And then within --
And then on top of that,
I was in Los Angeles.
So then it was
the weird thing of like,
"Oh, they're only like
15 minutes' drive away."
And so within about 32 hours
I was having breakfast
with the two of them
at their house, which was wild
-Now, these guys,
as you mentioned,
they're so enigmatic.
They're so stylized.
They're so unique.
Were you worried
that a lot of people
when they first saw a traile
would think this was a ban
you had made up
like, say, Spinal Tap?
-I mean, I think in a weird wa
it's a good way
to go into the film.
I think a lot of people --
One thing I want to stress
is you do not have to be
a fan of the band to enjoy it.
And I think, in a weird way,
if you've never heard them
before, it's quite a good wa
to see the movie.
And there are definitely som
people who saw it at festivals
who spent half
of the duration thinking,
"Wow. This is like
a really elaborate prank.
How did he do all this archive?"
Like it's some kind
of Banksy thing.
I mean, I was going
to say actually --
I wanted to say to you actuall
that I did an article for
Rotten Tomatoes the other da
where I listed my 10 favorit
music documentaries.
And the top nine were all real
and the number-10
wild-card choice
was "The Blue Jean Committee
Gentle and Soft"
"Documentary Now!"
I'm not kidding.
-We're very --
Thank you for putting us
in what I'm sure
is good company.
-Yeah, absolutely.
I mean -- So, I mean,
it is a nice way to see it
because I think for a lot
of people who watched it -
And when I was editing
the movie,
I kept road-testing it wit
friends during the pandemic.
And usually I sort out friends
who'd never heard of them.
And they all had
the same reaction.
They said,
"It is like sort of what --"
If you've never heard of the
before, it's like watching
a secret history of music
open up to you."
So that's kind of, you know --
But they're very real.
-You also must --
As a documentary filmmaker
obviously, you pick the subject,
but you must,
as you're putting it together --
There's such
great archival footage
thanks to the fact
that they were so unique.
You must fall in love with the
as a director in a way
that you had also fallen
in love with them as a fan
-Yeah, I mean, they're so --
I had gotten to know them
after the Twitter thing.
There was a sort of --
You know, maybe back two years
before it occurred to me
to make the documentary.
I knew what they were like
in person,
and the thing that I found
very endearing about them
is that they were
never, like, off the clock
And so there is a thing
that I guess --
So, watching this archive
and knowing them,
there is this thing
where the line
between Ron and Russell
as brothers
and the band
is just permanently blurred.
And I feel like they,
you know just, like,
are sort of Sparks 24/7.
And there's something
really admirable about tha
because they are the exception
in terms of
"don't meet your heroes."
You know, they're exactly
what you want them to be.
And the fact that
they're sort of so normal
makes them kind of even weirder.
[ Laughter ]
-I know exactly
what you're talking about.
Hey. Congrats again.
It's so wonderful, and I do hope
that we see you again
soon over here in the States
-Thank you.
I'll be back
with some essential work.
-That would be very nice.
We would appreciate that.
"The Sparks Brothers"
in theaters tomorrow.